liberals will win the battle for America
mr. rush viewers might be surprised to
hear that whether you right there is no
vast right-wing conspiracy no I don't
think there is Connie I think we have on
the Republican side and extraordinarily
well designed and well developed
movements financed by some major
conservative families and by Wall Street
and some big corporations in league with
right-wing evangelical Christians around
the country as their ground troops the
movement has been developed and designed
very carefully over the past 20 years it
has phrases and words that in or well
ian fashion had become very familiar to
us tax-and-spend liberal political
correctness class warfare words and
phrases that we hear reverberating on
right-wing talk radio and talk
television to such an extent that a lot
of Americans take them for granted the
entire system is very disciplined
Democrats are not disciplined by nature
by temperament Democrats also don't have
quite the ground troops labor unions
have traditionally been democratic
ground troops but in my view
unfortunately the private sector
unionization rate is down to about eight
point nine percent of the private sector
workforce so we don't have quite the
ground troops and there is not the same
dedicated sources of money on the
Democratic side as the Republican side
so this is not a cause for despair in
fact quite the contrary I'm very upbeat
I've never seen Democrats progressives
liberals more organized energized
mobilized that I have now for this
coming election one thing that george w
bush has done quite effectively is to
give the progressive liberal left in
this country a a cause to get together
overcome a lot of fragmentation a lot of
traditional differences and unite in the
cause of having a very different
administration come january you say that
the republicans are united yet we hear
enough in the recent days that there is
a rift in in within the republican
specifically over the war in iraq but
also over some other issues including
judicial nomination
what's your take on the the shift there
if well when there is yeah when things
get very tough I mean when public
opinion starts plummeting as it has for
this president and for his policies in
Iraq when the economy shows signs of
coming back but still most Americans
don't feel that their jobs are secure
and their health insurance is declining
then we do start seeing rifts in the
Republican Party because a lot of
Republicans want to be reelected and
they also want to stay in control of
Congress and the White House and so that
Republicans who normally are very
disciplined and normally are marching in
lockstep are beginning to panic you
mentioned religious conservatives if I
interpreted this right you tweak the
liberal religious organizations a little
bit in your book you say liberal-leaning
religious groups are doing a lot of good
in their communities but most are afraid
of getting involved in anything
resembling politics well the religious
left in America was very active as you
may remember in the civil rights
movement of the 1950s and 60s and also
the anti-war movement but since then the
religious left has become much quieter
in terms of national affairs for variety
of reasons and in the book when we talk
about the revival of progressive
Democrats and liberals I talked about
the importance of getting the religious
left back involved you also say that
working single and well educated women
constitute the potential ground troops
for the left absolutely working women
although they don't have very much time
they are politically active they can
become and will become much more
politically active and they are
overwhelmingly Democrat and liberal they
also are concerned about issues of early
childhood education of child care of
paid family and medical leave of ways of
balancing work and family that I think a
lot of young men are also becoming very
concerned about older men perhaps a
little bit set in our ways but even baby
boomer
are feeling the pressures as I did when
I was labor secretary the reason I left
you may recall was because I couldn't
achieve a balance between my work and
family and I had two young teenage boys
at home at the time and although it was
the best job I ever had it was the best
family and it is the best family I ever
had so I left my job and it was a very
good decision but many people are
finding that that pressure is building
for them and they need some relief the
the right talks about family friendly
and family values but it opposes
extending family medical leave providing
a paid family medical leave providing
additional child care just cut child
care expenditures awarding a big tax
break to the rich and cutting schools
and childcare had all sorts of other
things that working family needs while
working families late that's not being
family-friendly that's being family
unfriendly phone lines are open if you'd
like to join us you'll see those numbers
at the bottom of your screen 2025 8530
881 if you support Democrats 3880 if you
support President Bush and 3882 for all
others you call you have it well some
people call conservatives neo-cons or
certain conservatives neo-cons you have
a name in here called rad cons now
what's a rad con and how does it how
does it differ from a nail gun well a
neocon presumably is somebody who used
to be a Democrat and became a very
conservative Republican in foreign
policy that is a subcategory of my view
of very much larger group of radical
conservatives who are radical in the
sense that they see the world in terms
of good and evil both domestic policy
you're either lazy good-for-nothing
shiftless or you are productive member
of society you are either a sexual
deviant in this radical conservative
terminology and cosmology or you are a
traditional family values person and in
foreign policy you are either evil
against us or you're with us this
radical conservative view of the world
being divided between good and evil is
seductively simple
it makes a lot of Americans who hear it
at least superficially feel well it's
simple I can understand it but it is
very dangerous for the future because it
eliminates all debate and deliberation
all shades of grey all it reduces
tolerance in this country and leads to a
kind of politics of resentment and anger
a lot of radical conservatives want to
blame the plight of the working class in
terms of the loss of jobs and loss of
good wages on for example affirmative
action and blacks or on immigrants or on
women and professional women on feminism
feminization and on a lot of things that
really don't have much to do with what
has happened to the working middle class
but they're using that the anger and
frustration that many workers have to
demonize many groups in the society you
hear it every day if you want to listen
to Rush Limbaugh I don't recommend it or
you listen to fox Republican news or you
listen to a lot of the demagogues who
now overwhelm our media it is i think
divisive at a time in our nation's
history where most Americans are not
Democrats or Republicans you have two
phone lines here if you're democrat you
find one phone line if you support the
president other most Americans really
are want to think about issues they want
solutions to issues they don't like this
harsh partisanship they don't like the
screeds the yelling matches they want
solutions to our problems and I think
that that's why they're looking at this
administration John Ashcroft attack on
civil liberties this administration's
attack on environmental policy the cuts
in help for poor people and for
middle-class people the big rewards of
tax breaks to the rich that totally
failed foreign policy which is getting
more and more dangerous not reducing
terrorism but actually inflaming the
Middle East creating a larger
possibility of terrorism Americans are
looking at this in time we didn't we
didn't elect this we thought we were
elected a compassionate conservative
modern
government in fact we in fact didn't
even elect george w bush this is his
tenth book is called reason why liberals
will win the battle for america first
call clayton north carolina for robert
rush good morning yes good morning
Robert hi Clayton it's always a pleasure
to see you i love your contemplative
approach to a lot of the issues i think
you're really touched upon one of the
biggest problems that we have in America
is the by polarization of the dialogue
that we have and a lot of the short
cutted and short minded processes of
thinking which are really supplanted by
these these masters of hyperbole I have
I want one comment and then two issues
that I'd like for you to approach if I
may the first one the comment i couldn't
help but make this one because I'm
someone who's really I considerably a
progressive Democrat I was educated in
college by incredibly a incredibly
conservative individuals and their
temperament has taught me a lot about
constitutionality and things of that
nature but what I find a problem Wiz is
this with the with the group that is
what i call harshly christian when you
really get down to the deliberating
issues with them many of there are many
of their their articles of faith depend
upon their moil moral high ground that
they take and then when you get down to
it it's almost like that they use their
faith as a as a shield to protect them
and their eventual answer to anything
that's going on like in the middle east
is that better them than us sort of
scenario your question color my question
is this i do not believe in the i have a
professor richard cohen down in coastal
carolina university and myrtle beach you
who taught us about the fallacy of the
growth in the GDP or gross national
product Medicus is the example as if the
school blew up then the gdp would grow
gross national probably groves and the
insurance pay mountain stuff like this
my real question is is that my wife and
i am i'm 34 I work my wife works we're
trying to justify having a child and
being able to genuinely afford you know
the the the whips and scorns of life as
it worried because we're one catastrophe
away from all of our savings going and
we can't do that so we're
the economic growth that were supposedly
seeing happening if thirty five percent
of the corporate profits are making up
the growth and the stock market who one
percent owns about forty fifty percent
the other thirty percent is owned by ten
percent of people where is the growth
really happening at Clayton the economy
certainly is growing and over the last
25 years the American economy has gone
grown dramatically but you're absolutely
correct to ask who has got the benefits
of that growth in fact median wages and
benefits if you include benefits like
health benefits along with wages have
gone almost nowhere adjusted for
inflation and the bottom half of the
population in terms of income and wealth
really is pretty much stuck where they
have been for many years and this is
something that has gone on long before
the Bush administration but it is a huge
national concern the gap between people
at the top who are getting a big big
portion of this increasing national
wealth and everybody else is widening to
the point where we haven't seen in over
a hundred years the Gilded Age of the
1880s and 1890s is the closest
approximation we have which is why a big
tax break for the top 1% which is
exactly what the Bush administration has
provided in a two thousand one and two
thousand three tax cuts seems so morally
wrong as well as economically off-base
the top 1% didn't stimulate the economy
they spend as much as they want to spend
that's the definition of being rich you
already spend as much as you want to
spend if you get a tax break you're not
going to turn around and stimulate the
economy and in terms of supply-side
economics the notion that if you give a
tax break to people at the top they're
going to invest it in the United States
economy well this is an hour global
economy and if people get a big big tax
relief the estate tax disappears as its
disappearing they're likely to take
their savings and invest in China or
everywhere there's no reason why they
would invest in the United States so
trickle-down economics doesn't work
either as a rationale I think that I
progressive revival in this country does
have to have as one of its tenets that
average working people do better in
terms of health care in terms of better
pension
protection in terms of better wages and
salaries expanding the Earned Income Tax
Credit rising raising the minimum wage
for people at the bottom all of this has
got to be part of a progressive platform
to widen the circle of prosperity in
this country Tarver North Carolina go
ahead yes he's been thank you for having
[ __ ] okay my question is to former
Labor Secretary why was the Social
Security borek against when Social
Security was set up to not the
government to go in and borrow any money
from it and why do we can spend all
these names of dollars overseas that why
the government can't pay some of this
money that they owe Social Security back
and wouldn't so security be a lot better
off now than what it is now yeah you're
very you're very correct in worrying
about the fact that the government is
now using a lot of Social Security
proceeds to pay for all sorts of other
government activities including the war
against terror Social Security taxes
have gone up over the recent years most
Americans pay more pay more in payroll
taxes which include Social Security
taxes than they do in income taxes and
yet you may remember in fact you
probably do because you're raising this
as your call and question you may
remember the two thousand campaign there
was some discussion between Al Gore and
george w bush about a social security
lock box well you don't hear anything
about that lockbox any longer what's
happened is that even though people are
paying more in payroll taxes and Social
Security taxes all of that is going to
finance general revenues instead of
being put aside in some way for social
security so that when the baby boomers
actually get to the point in just a few
years of needing Social Security and
Medicare that Social Security Medicare
will be there but it's not going to be
there for a very long time Medicare
especially is in trouble and this
administration instead of shoring up and
protecting the Social Security of
Medicare system instead of having
lock box has raided in that system and
gives a big tax break to the rich uses a
lot of that money that could be used
used to protect Social Security and
Medicare and simply transforms it into a
tax break for the very wealthy that to
me is irresponsible we now have a five
hundred almost a five hundred billion
dollar deficit as far as the eye can see
the largest deficits in history and I
can tell you that this is almost exactly
what we had to face when we members of
the Clint administration and Bill
Clinton as president in 1993 took over
and had a huge gigantic deficit than
three hundred billion dollars a year as
far as the eye could see and the first
thing that Bill Clinton had to do and we
had helped him do was get that deficit
under control john kerry when he becomes
president in january will have to do
exactly the same thing we'll have to get
that deficit under control democrats
have become the party of fiscal
responsibility cleaning up these
Republican messes Akron Ohio I'm a
little nervous this is my first time
calling welcome sorry um don't be
nervous thank you I'm reading a book
right now called target the West it was
written in 1993 by Yosef padang ski and
it's really terrifying and I wanted to
know if the Democrats get back in charge
what do they plan on doing with this one
taryn could you please give me a good
answer on this thang up well it i don't
know the book you're referring to but i
understand why you are frightened i
think that we all should be frightened
we certainly had a direct experience on
911 with terrorism and the frightening
implications of terrorism here the
united states but the way you conquer
terrorism is number one you use an
international a truly international
police force and intelligence gathering
you work very closely with our allies in
NATO with our allies or traditional
allies you've worked very closely with
anybody in the developing world all
nations that also have an interest and
many of them do have a very strong
interest in conquering terrorism and
secondly you work to make sure that the
raley Palestinian situation is on a
piece track the Bush administration has
basically turned his back on that peace
process but that peace process is very
important because as long as that war
goes on in Israel between the Israelis
and the Palestinians you're going to
have a continuous a thorn in the side of
moderate Arabs who are trying to as best
they can gain a foothold politically and
finally you internationalize the Iraqi
war as fast as you possibly can you
shore up the moderates in Iraq shore up
the moderates in the Middle East you try
to reduce the radicalization that's now
going on every time the United States
participates or is shown to participate
in what appears to be an atrocity like a
blob that prison the prisoner tras days
we increase recruitment to terrorism we
actually run the risk of increasing
terrorism rather than reducing it this
administration assumes that bombs and
guns and military strategies and a kind
of go it alone unilateralism is the way
to reduce radicalism in the Middle East
and they couldn't be further from the
truth that kind of policy actually in
flames the Arab Street that kind of
policy increases recruitment to
terrorism and it makes the Arab
moderates across the region it puts them
in a much much more difficult position
Chicago hello hello you're on the air
please go ahead oh yes mr. rush I just
want to tell you that I love you as much
as i can love someone I've never met but
I you I think you're a true American
Hero I'll never forget the first
election I've ever voted in was the 92
election and you are so inspiring then
and you're still just doing such great
work and helping us to sink and you know
I read The American Prospect which I
know why I think you helped found it
anyway I just
ah I want to there's a I just I just
want to thank you I have a question but
I I want to thank you for someone like
you who is so brilliant and so talented
and not pompous and working for you know
a average Americans out here who are
suffering and I know you could make so
many gazillions of dollars working for
big corporations but I don't know and
your question caller I want to ask you
what what should we what do you want
advise ordinary people like me to do
whoo-hoo want our country to go in a
different and more humane and more
rational direction well the first thing
I'd advise is to get involved in
politics many people when they think
about politics they hold their nose and
they say it's dirty and I don't want
anything to do with it but actually
politics is the applied form of
democracy without politics we don't have
democracy without political engagement
we don't have democracy so I would urge
you and everybody else who is
politically interested enough to tune
into this program to devote two or three
or five or ten hours a week how much you
whatever you can to politics with regard
to the upcoming election get out the
vote drives getting on the telephone
raising money working with friends and
communities your associates but don't
stop there too many people assume that
the only real entry into politics is
presidential elections know that you
have to continue to be and go involved
and engaged in the presidential election
1936 somebody came up to Franklin D
Roosevelt and said mr. president I want
you to do if you're re-elected I want
you to do this this this and this and
President Roosevelt who was running for
reelection turn to the voter and said I
would love to do all of that but you
must make me and what did he mean by
that comment you must make me what he
meant was that any president only has a
limited amount of political capital to
get done what he or she wants to get
done
and a president relies on a mobilized
organized energized electorate behind
him or her to get anything done and so
that in some ways the most important
organizing and political challenge
occurs after election day if John Kerry
is elected as I hope he will be he needs
the support an active support of
millions of Americans to get health care
affordable healthcare in place to change
the course of the Middle East policy and
our quite mindless use of force in the
Middle East to improve education to get
bills through a Congress that may still
be at least partly Republican if not
wholly Republican I hope Democrats do
take back both houses of Congress but
nevertheless I remember back in 1994
Bill Clinton had a Democratic Congress
and obviously a Democratic presidency
but was unable to get through his health
care plan which granted was too
complicated by half but nevertheless the
public was not sufficiently organized
behind him to give him the support he
needed so again my advice to you get
involved for this election but also get
involved for the long term I'm asked
about the political conventions because
they there the Democrats are scheduled
in your state to meet and the Baltimore
Sun says this morning that mr. Kerry's
thoughts about possibly putting off his
nomination so that proposing such a
cynical tactic not only acknowledges
that nominating conventions are
meaningless but also suggests that the
process for public financing of
presidential campaigns is so broken that
it deserves to be gained well the
process for financing presidential
campaigns Connie is broken everybody
acknowledges that the arcane rules that
would permit otherwise that is if John
Kerry accepted the nomination at the
Democratic nominating convention that
would permit the Republicans george w
bush and company to continue to spend
money and would prohibit the Democrats
from Kenya tending to spend until the
Republican convention five or six weeks
later that is arcane that is unfair and
the way that John Kerry
is wisely seeking to remedy that in the
interim short of changing those rules
they can't change the rules now is to
accept the fact that a nominating
convention is mostly a national pep
rally and that's the way nominating
conventions have been for years I don't
remember in recent years a nominating
convention which really was a a vote in
any unanticipated way for the person who
had already been deemed the party's
candidate so he's just simply accepting
reality both of those realities Boston
Herald's editorial though this morning
says you that the Democrats knew this
going into going into making the
decision to have their convention at
this date well John Kerry can't be
tagged with what the Democrat I don't
know who the Democrats are or who the
Democrats were but the fact of the
matter is we're in a presidential
campaign John Kerry is in a presidential
campaign he doesn't want to go into the
summer with one hand tied behind his
back that would be insane everybody
knows that he will be the Democrats
candidate it's not as if he is pulling
the rug out from under some process
where everybody is otherwise scratching
their heads and saying yeah I wonder who
the Democratic candidate is going to be
no he's acknowledging the reality that
he is already the presumptive candidate
and he's also acknowledging the reality
that the arcane rules of campaign
finance would give the Republicans a
ridiculous advantage where he not to
take the action he's now taking
Jacksonville Florida good morning
morning good morning oh my goodness John
Kerry new really what the days of the
convention was during this campaign but
nevertheless um you know I have to take
I have to dispute done with your
statements today and I'm a little
concerned I'm also old nervous don't be
nervous um you know you talked about
initially about the spokespersons the
rush limbaugh's etc but you forgot to
say about the personal hatred spewed by
the Paul Begala James Carville from Al
Franken's on the left
and you know I think if you want to be
fair and balanced you need to mention
both and say it's a problem in both area
but parties not just the Republicans and
also you said the Republicans bling
blacks women immigrants etc for the loss
of jobs and that's just not true that's
just absolutely not true how about the
high-tech how about this becoming a
service economy and no longer an
industrial society it's a matter of
changes that do occur throughout history
and you know that you're too smart not
to know that thanks Florida we'll leave
it at that well let me take both of your
points in order first of all in my book
the new book reason I do criticize
Democrats as well as Republicans I don't
like the politics of character
assassination I didn't like the way
Democrats treated Robert Bork in his
nomination fight in the late 1980s I'd
attested the way the Republicans treated
President Clinton in that terribly
sordid affair in the 1990s late 1990s
with Monica Lewinsky I don't like the
way talk radio and television which with
due respect to mr. Begala and James
Carville and Al Franken talk radio and
talk television is totally dominated by
right-wing conservatives Rush Limbaugh
is appears on 600 stations Al Franken
appears on three there's no comparison I
don't sanction anybody using personal
invective to undermine somebody else's
argument by going after them personally
that doesn't seem to me to be a sensible
way of conducting public dialogue what
we need in this country is more
discussion of the issues more discussion
of why we are heading in the wrong
direction if in fact we are I believe we
are and what can be done to write the
course of this country your second point
with regard to loss of jobs make sure
that you understand what I said the
radical conservatives who dominate the
media and dominate much of the white
house in Congress have in my view too
often blamed the loss of jobs and also
the plight of working-class Americans
the plight of working-class America
who are still very much struggling to
make ends meet blamed blacks affirmative
action blamed women feminists rush
limbaugh cause of feminized isvalid
nazis blamed immigrants there's a lot of
very very anti immigrant invective on
our radio waves and on television coming
mostly from the right wing also blame
foreigners and you are correct I mean
the real source of the problem with
regard to our jobs has to do with
globalization and technology we need
better education better job training we
need things like and I have suggested
the past wage insurance so if you lose
your wages going from one job to the
next job you get at least a portion of
the wages back for a certain period of
time we need an active government that
supports people with regard to health
care and child care we're on the same
boat and so I am with you in terms of
getting away from personal invective
these kind of screeds this kind of very
mean-spirited politics that we've had
for a number of years and getting back
to practical solutions to help ordinary
working Americans al da stage or J hi
mr. rush i have to thank you for your
civility and brilliant this morning as
well breath of fresh air my question is
I think a lot of people are afraid to
say it for the most part and I don't
mean this to be I'm certain it's going
to be crass but I don't I don't want it
to seem as though it's an attack on our
president but at the same time he
doesn't seem convincing in labor matters
or world affairs geopolitical issues etc
because he seems to lack the acumen or
the area addition that a leader would
have Quentin was was very sharp very
bright Carrie seems to resemble that and
other ways also and you know it just
seems as though I wouldn't call him I
wouldn't say that he lacks knowledge but
he lacks that disposition that that's
autistic accurate academic disposition
that makes him seem almost brutal at
various points um what's your comment on
that sir well I i think that Paul
O'Neill the former secretary of the
Treasury put it best in his recent book
when he said that the president seemed
not to be
able to listen to different points of
view seem very fixed in his views that
seemed almost stubbornly fixed not able
to exercise judgment with regard to a
wide array of arguments didn't even want
to consider other arguments and I think
that's what we've seen with regard to
the Iraqi policy as it continues to fail
as its views more and more violence as
our solutions run out as many generals
are beginning to come forward and saying
we are on the wrong track this
administration simply refuses to
acknowledge that what we heard the
president say last night was very much a
continuation of what he has said to date
nothing new no acknowledgement of the
failings of the past no sense of
personal responsibility and fundamental
change in thinking we've seen the same
thing in economic policy the president
still says that big tax cuts for the
rich makes sense doesn't seem to
acknowledge that we have almost 500
billion dollar-a-year deficits as far as
the eye can see doesn't acknowledge that
environmental policies are actually
working to hurt the environment not help
the environment despite words like the
clean forest initiative education
policies the No Child Left Behind Act I
think had some good things in it but it
was not fully funded and it's causing
chaos around the country talked to
almost any school and you'll see that so
one by one the policies of this
administration are failing but the
president is not acknowledging those
failures and seeking to change you know
the Ralph Waldo Emerson once said that
consistency is the hobgoblin of the
little minds yes you want your political
leaders to be consistent but when things
go wrong when new facts are revealed
showing that there have been errors made
in the past in terms of policy judgments
you want your your leaders to
acknowledge those errors and change the
ways they are going about undertaking
public policy and I think the problem
with this president is there doesn't
seem to be any capacity to accept error
and to change and that is frankly quite
worried LaSalle Michigan yes good
morning morning thank you for taking my
call I try to be real quick
I think I can do this in about a minute
and a half because you covered so much
ground and you so thoroughly slandered
conservatives this morning I have to
refute some of this if you'll please
allow me um you guys claim to be the
champion of tolerance and you show your
own intolerance by complaining about
free speech in this country because
certain conservatives have carved
themselves without a little niche in the
media I think that that's a glaring
example of liberal hypocrisy and
duplicity I think liberalism stands for
nothing more than three major points
balded overbearing fatuous bureaucracies
oppressive taxation on American citizens
no matter what their tax bracket you
have nothing to offer brutal enemies in
this world in a dangerous world but
appeasement and pacifism and the only
thing you can do for your constituents
and to keep them voting for you is to
keep them in poverty and servitude and I
can prove that by looking at the Great
Society of Lyndon Johnson are you going
to tell me mr. rice in this modern era
we've been fighting a war on poverty I
live I live right down the road from
Detroit Michigan and i can tell you
since the war on poverty and the Great
Society the big liberal Bugaboos of the
1960's have been initiated the Detroit
ghetto has gotten worse and every other
ghetto in this country has gotten worse
they are more violent they're more crass
they are more dangerous liberalism
stands for appeasement in the face of
brutal enemies bigger government and
oppressive taxation period well you
don't seem to like liberals very much I
hope you read my book and I hope at
least you open yourself up to the
possibility that liberals and Democrats
have some answers but let me go through
the individual points you raised first
of all you say that conservatives have a
as you put it a little niche in the
middie media well I don't know what
media you're listening to because
opinionated talk radio and talk
television I'm talking about talk radio
and television where the host has a very
strong opinion puts his opinion out or
her opinion that is completely dominated
and it's been very well documented that
it's totally dominated by very
right-wing conservatives right now
and I could go back and give you that
documentation if you want but believe me
just just turn on your car radio or turn
on your television tune into Fox
Republican news and you'll hear what I
have to say we you'll understand why I
make that point you say that liberalism
is equated with big government well we
have not had a government nearly this
large as we now have under george w bush
the current Conservative radical
conservative administration has created
a big government far bigger spending is
out of control deficits are completely
out of control this is a government that
is snooping on private Americans under
the Patriot Act John Ashcroft is looking
at library cards or he is authorizing
people to and his agents to look at
people's library cards and to spy on
email this is a big government and a big
government that is dangerously out of
control it's a big government that is
carrying on a quite a dangerous military
a unilateral military experiment that is
arguably and I think it's likely
increasing terrorism rather than
reducing it so don't talk about
liberalism as being or liberals being
favored by government radical
conservatives under george w bush have
created the largest and most encroaching
government i remember in my time you say
that liberals are in charge or in favor
pacifism well you have to understand i
guess you don't know your facts you
don't you know your history and world
war two it was liberals who wanted to
take on Nazism and fascism it was
conservatives were isolationists that
was the case really for most of the 20th
century liberals have taken on the
bullies the the the powers that have
have really threatened this country it
has been liberal democrats who have
taken us many times kicking and
screaming into war not always
successfully I might add Vietnam was a
terrible scar on this country but it was
liberals and Democrats that were to a
large extent responsible for that and
finally you say the Great Society Lyndon
Johnson's Great Society was a terrible
failure again you've got your facts
wrong during the Great Society when we
Lyndon Johnson created Medicare we
started head starts the Job Corps a lot
of programs that actually reduced
inequality in this country created
opportunities for countless millions of
people we have not yet returned to the
degree of equality of opportunity that
we had during that Great Society
millions of elderly people who were
condemned to poverty were relieved from
poverty because of what Lyndon Johnson
did in that Great Society what's
happened since then is that
unfortunately inequality has widened
poverty has increased not because the
Great Society but because we abandoned
so many of those programs and abandoned
some many of those ideals Petaluma
California a good morning morning to
rise all right first of all it's really
a privilege to speak with you and to be
on c-span as my second call ever I I
wanted to ask you what what would be
your advice or your suggestion I do view
you as a voice of reason and I I like
the name of your book it fits you well
what could the average person's action
plan B we listened last night to
President Bush's list of what I call
kind of wishes not really a plan no
strategy visible anywhere on the horizon
and I do what I can I write I
communicate I active in my and vocal in
my views and support for our party the
Democratic Party but I think that that
on a very basic level since we are all
struggling to pay taxes in to work every
day a simple action plan for the average
person is we approach this election it's
so easy to get bogged down in in the
heat I can get overheated in in a minute
with some of the issues but I think what
we need is a voice of reason you're one
of them guiding us with some with some
simplistic steps that that almost anyone
could could take and work on as we try
to turn this around Thanks California
well let me suggest some simple steps to
you I know that politics seems pretty
daunting and some of the challenges
America faces right now particularly in
foreign policy seemed far beyond the
capacity of ordinary Americans to do
anything about but it's that sense of
being overwhelmed and that sense of
being daunted and that sense of sort of
skepticism bordering on cynicism that
you can have any effect that is the
greatest obstacle to people taking back
democracy so what I would suggest to you
is that you look at your weekly calendar
and you identify at least two hours
hopefully more than that maybe five or
even ten hours that you could devote to
politics now let me be clear about what
I mean and a lot of people say to me
well where am I going to get my two
hours or three hours or five hours I'm
working all the time as it is and I'm
cleaning up the house and I have kids
and I don't have any time well turn off
the television maybe you could get some
time there but what you do with regard
to those two or three or five hours is
you go to your local either you're John
Kerry Committee headquarters or your
Democratic Party headquarters go to the
Internet go to various places where
there are lists of very specific things
where you could take part in politics
their tasks that are not on the face of
it very romantic or exciting but they're
very important tasks getting out the
vote writing letters calling people in
swing states maybe you have friends
maybe you have relations in Ohio or
Pennsylvania or Wisconsin or Michigan or
west virginia or missouri or Florida or
any state that is a really a swing state
and maybe you can devote some time to
talking to those people getting them
activated and involved maybe you might
even be able to and I don't think most
people can but maybe unite might even be
able to take some time out this summer
or in september-october and go to some
of these states you're in California
California is pretty safe for the
Democrats but don't take anything for
granted you are needed also in
California in terms of your voice and
your work and getting out the vote you
have your own website well I don't
really have a website but anybody can
find me if you write in Robert rice re i
CH google and there a couple of websites
that do have my articles and also all my
writings and had everything else they
would like to know thank you very much
for joining us Robert righteous new book
is published by Cano is called reason
why liberals will win the battle for
America